Anagrams [are] words made out of the letters of another word for instance Britney Spears can be rearranged to spell
Presbyterians
Michael David Stevens can Spell
I'm the cave devil sand and as the title tells you mel Gibson has big melons
But are these the best celebrity [wordplay] anagrams of all time to find out more all aboard the boat?
Justin Timberlake says I'm a jerk but listen and Tom cruise says I'm so cuter
Rob Pattinson is not top brains but clint Eastwood can deliver old West action and
Richard Nixon's vice President Spiro agnew grow up
Moving on to women heidi Montag
Imagined hot Jennifer Aniston is fine in
torn jeans and your mother-in-law
She's a woman hitler
snooze alarms yell out alas
No more z's
slot machines get cash lost in them and the most common thing in a dormitory is the dirty room
Some special anagrams don't even require rearrangement just spaces for instance
psychotherapists can Become psycho the rapist and
When the irs looks at your income they're going to say that some of it is
Theirs but here's a doozy the alphabet itself can be rearranged to spell a sentence
It's not easy
but here you go umph your bank lifts vexed quiz a
[combe] is a [bowl-shaped] region made by a glacier [a] ford is a narrow inlet with steep sides and a quiz is a test
But it's also a name you could give someone who's eccentric
So the sentence means that glyphs on the bank of a hollow near an inlet
irritated a weird person
Nice, and now that we're this deep into it
Why not talk about palindromes these are words or sentences that are the same forwards and backwards race car?
Kayak [D]. Leveled Lonely Tylenol rise to vote sir meat animals
Laminate them and of course. Go hang a salami. I'm a lasagna hog, or
This from Comedian Demetri Martin damn it. I'm mad
It's an entire poem that reads the same forwards and backwards [I]
Made all the animations in this video using the internet and a graham server
It's a cool place where [you] can type in words and the computer will find out what's hidden in them another good one is
Anagram genius it's by far my favorite go check that out using a link in the description
And figure out what's hidden inside your name?
Or other people's names and come back here and leave in the comments below the funniest things you find
Oh, and flash Swanky, Satanic [warthog]. [I] mean as always. Thanks for watching